how many months to prepare for this and
how long did they tell you that it
should be I got the call in February
they said do 15 minutes
I started trying to structure what I
wanted to do first before I got writers
involved and then the news kept changing
and then Marge comes right yeah so it's
beginning to March I got my guest
hosting week at The Daily Show top of
April so I got to start thinking about
topics for that and my problem was that
anything I want to do for the dinner
well should I do it on a Daily Show
maybe let's put that on the day that's a
better place so I just didn't think
about it at all until after my guest
week which gave me a three-week Runway
which kind of works because the biggest
stories broke the week of five days
before the dinner Tucker Carlson and Don
Lemon get fired Ron DeSantis joke
the Ron DeSantis Shrine is the only
thing that survived from February till
the night one joke every other joke just
got remixed we had Fox News jokes but
then Tucker took over that whole run so
yeah the Fox News run became mostly
about Tucker then the Clarence Thomas
stuff I had a CRT joke and then the
Clarence Thomas stuff leaks about him
taking the unpaid vacation
good merges well together so that's a
phenomenal joke great joke
yeah and so like just as news kept
breaking we just kept I mean like the
first draft bro we had Chinese spy
balloon jokes yeah it's like yeah you
had a little tag but there was drive-by
yeah you can't sit in it no more and
talk about how the media obsessed those
things people don't care no more yeah
also there's a Katt Williams spy balloon
joke like you know I'm like obsessed
with like with what other comedians
saying about the thing somebody somebody
posted some cell phone footage of Katt
Williams from a set earlier this year
and but his spy balloon material yeah
y'all don't even need to address that
topic now he got it he got it he owns
that topic and not only that his joke
Works in an Evergreen Way and I couldn't
figure out how to tell because that's
the other thing with the correspondence
center it's just timely it's topical
you've got to be about what's happening
right now and I couldn't figure out a
way to do the Spy balloon in that way
but then you know we start huddling up a
lot of writers oh okay here's a way to
just sneak it in yeah so when was the
set finalized
bro we was texting from the table on the
night wow [__] was at the
podium and they're texting and they're
going voucher's in here you got anything
about fauci I'm like oh I think I can
come up with something about that and is
that coming on to the teleprompter no so
you just got to put that in I gotta drop
it in just at some point the Brittany
Griner joke
like just that little Quick Pass I
didn't know she was going to be there
until I saw her on the red carpet was
she oh she was there she was there she
didn't know she was going to be there
until probably
yeah that red carpet was flashback she's
like God damn it these Soviets again
your [__]
so that Biden napron where you know
Biden gets work done between navs and
love yeah why didn't they show your face
during that did you notice I don't know
they I don't know they must have known
once you send them the prompter they
know and they're like I'm not gonna let
him act out Joe so it's just cut to some
cowboy in the audience who's like yeah
seriously
also they don't need audience cutaways
in this [__] I'm so confused why they do
that
for a state of specials I get it but for
this specifically it's like that
audience there's always someone on
camera that's not doing what the other
people are doing yeah yeah the cut shot
is always like well what the [__] is he
doing like what is he talking about the
one time when they showed Trump like
four years ago or five years ago
remember when he's just Stone facing
stealing [__] yeah that is the great
that's a great time okay they should
keep the cut away
I was praying he pulled up bro yeah he's
not gonna I thought that was so [__]
that he didn't come yeah I was praying
he pulled up you see that's why you
figure like somebody like Killian Conway
or go back to trouble it was a good time
you should go yeah and then it'd be your
ass up there next year
a whole different game I mean imagine
that so did you have some jokes for
people that didn't show up that you
pulled out no because I wasn't that's
the one thing I don't subscribe to just
because you ain't here don't mean I
ain't gonna talk about your ass if
you've been wilding out yeah I'm
supposed to not talk about Clarence
Thomas because he didn't show up yeah I
just think if you got jokes about people
that you have to do jokes about some of
the people that are there I think to
earn the right to do the other jokes the
only joke I was really nervous about was
the school shooting what happened with
the school shooting
it was fine to me I don't care is that
the intention of the joke
yeah just to just say pass gun laws
without getting into yeah
like you don't want to I thought that
was the ballsiest joke to do that three
and a half minutes in
you could lose not just the room the
entire country because they don't have
crazy trust in you you know what I mean
you got one Dominion voting booth [__]
that hit that's a joke you put you
tucked 30 minutes into a special you're
doing it three minutes in to a speech
for the entire world
what could have cost you and it hit
which was amazing I have to kick you in
the teeth
or else I don't earn the right to Let's
fail the Biden joke off the top what
Comedy Club so good like you saw me at
the cellar the dark Brandon well I
didn't get that what is the mean thing
that was that was a joke back from if
you watch it online you don't it's a
call back to what Biden said earlier oh
yeah let's go Brandon reference it's
Biden leaning into people calling him
brain he goes I'm dark Brandon now
basically I'm a tough guy oh so he says
a thing to Roy where he's like I'm ready
for your jokes but I don't know about
dark Brandon and then he puts on the
glass oh
he is
like it's there was a joke at the top
and you saw me coming to The Comedy
Cellar running it yeah every night
certain jokes you can't do in the club
like all you can do is guess the the
main punch lines but like that the first
joke is me hand and Biden back his
classified documents yeah I like that
yeah if that doesn't work how [__] am
I yeah yeah yeah yeah your first joke at
a corporate gig yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we've been there they don't they don't
they don't they're just people in there
like oh so they got a prop comment
so we got black characters
yeah but they laughed and so then it's
like okay let me do one joke on myself
so hey I look like Keenan Thompson
giggle yeah okay let's do a quick Santos
joke giggle giggle giggle school
shootings [__] yeah yeah like
that's where you have to go but you knew
when you said it that they were gonna
groan correct and then you had that line
at the end which I thought was
submissive don't grow into me past
legislation yeah just passed legislation
which is such a good like [__] you
you're not gonna sit here in moral
Heights you're groaning because it's
true so if you've got a problem with it
change it do something about it so from
there then you can get into the people
and all of that stuff I just think you
gotta I gotta come on stage and in two
minutes I gotta prove to you that I'm
funny and worth paying attention to then
we have to establish where the line is
and so the school shooting joke is to
establish the line like it's I mean you
know this [__] is sociology bro like
it's just manipulating people in a
certain way so that they stay with you
long enough to get to the next joke or
to the next joke and to the next joke
and then once you have
kind of people in a pocket then you can
do the Clarence Thomas joke like the
original intention was to do the
Clarence Thomas joke higher in the set
but then I'm like if they don't know
where I'm coming from they gotta trust
you yeah trust me that one you're taking
them on a journey it's a long walk yeah
yeah no I didn't earn that walk yet okay
now speaking of of jokes that may or may
not be uh in this roast
um we asked if there were certain jokes
that you did not include now you're
saying nobody edited your [__] no one
edited it did you have anybody pull you
aside and invite you to an island to
[__] teenagers if you didn't say any
jokes about them no they did not uh I
did not get the the invitation not at
all no no so I guess I wasn't funny
enough
don't make fun
[Applause]
his mom ran it
nah I gotta I I can say with all honesty
man nobody policed me it was people who
were in those particular camps who knew
that I was going to have something from
like like I did CNN Friday morning
before
before the shooting the week of the Don
Lemon firing and like some of the
producers of CNN I said
tomorrow about this is
yeah I have to say something about what
the hell happened here like yeah his
picture is still on the wall
you're taking them down with the
decoration yet yes I have to bring that
up so it was more people who knew that
they were targets it was the same thing
a couple years ago when I did the
Congressional correspondence dinner
which is like the like the AAA Ball
version of this [__] and it was the same
time when Megan Kelly had got fired or
whatever from NBC and NBC people were
all up in my face like are you gonna say
anything about me let's get to some of
these jokes
now now understanding all of the meanest
ones by the way just the meanest ones
you don't want all the [__] no okay so
to me the issue was this bro
some of the jokes were so mean that it
would jeopardize this structural
Integrity of jokes that came after it
okay
when you understand what I like the way
you break down comedy it's just like
inside baseball you don't know me these
people don't know me
so I cannot just be this vile out the
gate because you don't know me yeah and
then if I'm too vile near the end of the
joke run it undermines the sincerity Mom
and Dad [__] that I put at the end
because which was a great original
choice is it true that that woman wasn't
actually your mom you actually hired an
actor
that was my mom wait a minute are you
wait don't stop
they just cut this yeah
who's that lady
okay only the mean ones now some of
these are cut for tone because they
would break up the Cadence of the Act
and the way I wanted to dosey doe
between left right wing jokes yeah some
of these were cut for time
all right okay so this is coming off of
the joke about
um Kamala Harris and that no Dick Cheney
you know Dick Cheney had a documentary
and if you're a vice president and you
got a documentary that means you vice
president it wrong yeah
Ain't No Other vice president had a
documentary well Al Gore had a
documentary but it wasn't about being
vice president it was about something
far more boring saving the Earth
we don't care about the Earth we all
gonna get killed at a shopping mall I
just don't want to die in a Spencer's
Gifts here we go you gonna kill me
you're the Nordstrom's baby that's what
oh yeah if you want to kill me kill me
at the Nordstrom's that's fine uh but we
cut it because we already had school
shooting jokes so we didn't need to do
double shoot jokes
um is it me or is Donald Trump the most
snitch known president of all time
nobody Stands Tall with the president
even Epstein had your lane Maxwell
obvious reasons
um
our media works hard they uncover a lot
of Horrors in this country like migrant
child workers
or as Republicans call it the solution
to childhood obesity
was that was that part of Michelle
Obama's let's move initiative let's move
those pallets until three in the morning
as an altar that I had uh the food was
delicious tonight yes it was picked by
migrant child workers good right
exactly that's why I didn't do it
it would have been a good opening though
uh Mike Pence was good at playing hide
and seek on January 6.
um oh yeah here we go now you'll know
why I cut this one uh the only time I
ever heard about Mike Pence doing
anything is vice president is when he
was playing hide and go seek with Trump
supporters on January 6. and Mr
President Biden the only thing I
remember about your time as vice
president is that you cussed a lot and
honestly I don't think that was that big
of a [__] deal you were the [__]
vice president and now you're the
[__] president you should be able to
say what the [__] you want
and then off Biden's reaction oh you're
not cussing Anymore
Joe Biden always flip-flopping on the
issues
yeah yeah wordy yeah long long long
sitting president yeah but on C-Span
it's like yeah
um now now while you still look for some
we also have a couple that we thought
that you might like oh Jesus
we
put a couple I'm sure just a few okay
and uh and you can read them we actually
printed them out so that you can read
them however you'd like oh that's so
nice here yeah you know what I mean it
won't affect your career opportunities
at all it's always a [__] ride when I
come to the flame
okay ready so what would we like to
start with do we want to start with
um
I'm sure these are better than anything
here you go here you go here you go
here's a good one this is about
um
okay
here's your single okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there we go
some major shakeups in journalism lately
we'll limit out and Tucker out Network
news has asked more members than a
medieval transgender Clinic
okay
medieval okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
remember penis yeah all right okay uh
okay okay here we go okay okay we'll
stay on the news we'll stay on the news
[Laughter]
Tucker Carlson's been fired his absence
at Fox News is actually the only gaping
hole that Don Lemon wouldn't fill
okay we're talking okay what about this
one this is a good one about Florida
yeah let's see what about
[Laughter]
Florida's gay policies are incredibly
strict you're not allowed to say gay
matter of fact if you're hiv-positive
run the scientist calls you Disney Plus
okay okay okay what about that what
about this one minted are you
[__]
[Laughter]
sidebar before I read this one and I'm
gonna read it
I only did
but the only woman I did a joke against
was Kamala just because of the weird
part because the thing the thing that I
was like really like concerned about is
like [__] trying to take a joke
and then we're gonna use it in the wrong
way against you on Sunday morning like
like the [__] I said about Don Lemon
[__] is weaponizing against him
right now and I'm like yeah but also
said that they hired Charles Barkley
which to me isn't the equivalent to Don
Lemon Charles talked that [__] but Don
also regardless of whatever he did off
camera did my [__] get on camera and
hold my [__] accountable and ask me I
ain't never seen Charles Barkley like
ask a pushback question and that's
what's going to be missing and so you
know I just think that
if I did a Nikki Haley joke or if I did
if I can
um Dianne Feinstein or any of those
topics it's like it's a it's a thin line
of getting that joke right without
somebody going you're just a man picking
on a woman so it's definitely is not
that no no
let's take a moment to recognize the
hard-working Americans that have endured
trains dumping toxic loads all over them
we're thinking about you Stormy Daniels
I love that I love that
but why should pick on that poor girl
come on come on right do you understand
the groans that would have come from the
room like Stormy Daniels
come on
because they thought you were going to
say East Palestine but it's really a
horror
yeah
oh yeah okay uh okay uh okay here this
this is uh okay here you go this this
one is this is why I come this one's
right this one's sweet this one's this
one's a sweet one
okay uh Joe Biden is here but he doesn't
know that she has such a lifeless
brainless corpse I'm surprised Trump
hasn't already [__] him
damn that's good
that's a good joke joke wise that's good
you're [__] right then Joe Biden's up
and he walks out Saturday
but imagine
oh that was amazing yeah it would prove
he's alive yeah nothing else and he
trips down the stairs this one
definitely is fine I haven't picked one
of them okay
yeah yeah yeah
all right all right I'll give you this
one
Mr President you did a great job with
your jokes
you know the problem with this show is
that I have to do this one at the top
yeah immediately which I'm done for the
rest of that probably if I open with
this joke yeah my documents joke much
safer yes yes Mr President you did a
great job with your jokes you got those
lines down so perfect Hunter tried to
snort the night
everybody
imagine him looking at you with his
lifeless smile
yeah where would they cut for that joke
Hunter they should have had a cam for
him they cut the bottom one time it
looked like he was lost
he was facing the wrong way reaction
the first time but I'll vote this time
[__] I should have had y'all writing for
me because it's easier to tone down than
punch out
like I know how to take those jokes and
okay I know how to
pay my son's [__] College
I gotta rework that one in school yeah
pay some bills yeah yeah uh Joe Biden is
so old that he thinks Kamala and I are
sitting on the same side of the room for
legal reasons
this little segregation action uh
every CNN
every CNN anchor is gone
all that's left is Blitzer and Tapper
which is what Cuomo used to do to the
female interns
[Laughter]